i don't understand why people want the
the reason for the divorce to be
something so so bad
is it's not nothing nothing crazy
out of this world happens sometimes
people really do
grow apart cardi b is shedding a little
light on her split
from offset i just got tired of
arguing i got tired of not seeing things
out of eye so before
when when you feel like it's just not
the same anymore
before you actually get cheated on i'd
rather just leave you know what i'm
saying
the wap rapper filed for divorce from
her husband of three years last
tuesday and on friday she hit up
instagram live to candidly address the
real reason she's walking away from her
marriage
i want to let y'all know i have not shed
not once here
you know every single time that you know
this guy have done
something so crazy so and it hits the
media i'm always
crying i'm always stressed out i'm sad
because
i don't like that type of [ __ ] this time
i wasn't crying you wanna know why
because it wasn't
the reason why of my divorce is not
because of none of that [ __ ] that ever
happened before
it's not because of cheating i'm seeing
people like oh he has a baby on the way
that's a whole complete lie just a
little refresher
cardi and offset tied the knot in
september 2017.
but their marriage was plagued by
cheating rumors for years
then the two welcomed their daughter
culture into the world in july 2018
and in december of that year cardi took
to instagram to reveal that she and the
migos
rapper were not together anymore but one
month later
she told e.t this working it out
yeah taking it slow fast forward to last
week
rumors started swirling that the reason
cardi filed for divorce from
offset was because he's expecting a
child with another woman
oh snappity-snap snap a source at the
time told e.t
the speculation was simply not true why
i wanted to be a baby
why i wanted to be all he cheated again
why like it's like you you're not in a
relationship you don't know how
relationship go
y'all want me to get cheated on 15 times
before i leave you want to
have a kid before i leave it doesn't it
no
sometimes you want to stop it before it
gets to that
so stop bringing up these fake rumors
and while the two had been on and off
for years they were seemingly
solid before the split oh no no no man
everything's good
in august cardi told elle magazine quote
i do know that my relationship has
a lot of drama but there's a lot of love
there's a lot of passion there's a lot
of trust
there's a big friendship it's always us
against the world
i've been with this man for four years
i've been i have a kid with this man
i have a household with this man
sometimes you just want
you just you're just tired of the of of
of the arguments of the buildups
you get tired sometimes and before
something bad happens before you get
left before you get cheated on
you sometimes you just want to leave